i
ah
el gobierno alemán explicó que ya logró
asegurar unos 300 millones de dosis de
la vacuna contra el coronavirus ya sea a
través de acuerdos bilaterales o de
acuerdos negociados en conjunto por la
comisión europea y también explicó que
es optimista de que pueda empezar a
entregar las primeras dosis de la vacuna
aquí en alemania ya sea a finales de
este año oa comienzos del próximo es
probable que la vacuna vaya a ser
entregada en unos 60 centros de
vacunación masiva que están siendo
desarrollados alrededor del país 6 de
ellos aquí en la capital berlín y
algunos de ellos en lugares como
pabellones donde normalmente se realizan
ferias comerciales o terminales de
aeropuertos en desuso las autoridades
alemanas también han indicado que está
desarrollando registros electrónicos
para determinar no solamente quién ha
sido vacunado sino también qué posibles
efectos secundarios se van conociendo la
vacuna estará disponible en primer lugar
para quiénes están en grupos de alto
riesgo seguido por personas que trabajan
en el sector de salud o que trabajan en
profesiones consideradas
levantes para la vida pública como
policías o profesores
[Música]
en medio de la segunda ola de kobe 19
con restricciones a un europa se está
preparando ya para la aprobación y
distribución de la vacuna contra la cob
y 19 por el momento la unión europea
tiene contratos con 5 farmacéuticas para
asegurarse 1200 millones de dosis los
países europeos son los que deciden cómo
distribuir esta vacuna entre su
población pero la comisión europea que
es la que coordina la compra de las
dosis ha hecho una serie de
recomendaciones sobre a quién vacunar
primero
bruselas que de que debe priorizarse a
los trabajadores esenciales como
cuidadores de ancianos sanitarios
también los mayores de 60 años o las
personas con enfermedades
cardiorrespiratorias la comisión europea
además tiene presupuestados 2.400
millones de euros para esta vacuna para
asegurarse que en cuanto se dé luz verde
a su aprobación la población europea
pueda armonizar se lo antes posible
contra la competición
[Música]
los estadounidenses podrían empezar a
recibir la vacuna a partir de la segunda
semana de diciembre así lo aseguró
moisés slow y científico en jefe de la
operación wordpress peter la encargada
de la distribución de la vacuna en eeuu
estado y dice que eeuu podría alcanzar
la inmunidad de rebaño en mayo del 2021
si un 70 por ciento de la población es
vacunada facer que ya aplicó para
obtener la aprobación de la vacuna por
parte de la fed a espera a producir más
de 50 millones de dosis antes de que
termine el año
gobernada por su parte aplicará esta
semana para la aprobación la rda se
reunirá el 10 de diciembre para aprobar
o no las vacunas los primeros en
recibirlas serán los trabajadores de la
salud y los pacientes más necesitados
sin embargo no hay una estrategia
nacional clara de distribución por la
falta de coordinación por parte del
gobierno saliente y el gobierno entrante
así que serán los estados los encargados
de liderar este proceso
[Música]